welcome guys come on guys how are you oh
hi doing we were talking about the word
record-holder for eating the most big
man just say this thirty thousand Big
Mac he's actually healthier than you
think like he should be just be dead
yeah looks like everyone who's ever
killed a hooker in supersize oh really
yeah now he's still doing it that we
just talked about that was twenty five
thousand now he's at thirty thousand big
match yeah
does he have an essential philosophy to
back up this eating you know I don't
remember if you're well I think it's OCD
yeah you really enjoy like they're tasty
and he likes them yeah I mean that's a
pretty solid tenet as far as I'm
concerned because probably if it ain't
broke don't fix it philosophy like I
like this meal so I just eat that meal I
mean how many diet fads have come and
gone who's to say in 40 years
yes just like ruthlessly efficient with
money with time it's just he's just he's
crushing something on the side we don't
know what it is but you know what I mean
maybe he's just getting it done maybe
this is I think it's an OCD thing I
think oh yeah I've actually spoken to
him and his theory is that cryogenic
freezing does not work and very
expensive but the preservatives right in
these sandwiches he's trying to do it
now oh he's cheap brother by the time
he's done he I mean his body's gonna be
set for four years anybody never gets
food poisoning because he can't I mean
if you just eat fast food all the time
because you know why yeah he can't get
food poisoning because he is food we
have to ask you guys to a wild wild
country was so good oh thanks I mean it
was a heat Sam turned me on to it and I
first it was so interesting I was like
is this really a documentary or is it
just Jim texted me after like the first
episode he's like this is fake right you
guys yeah like and I'm like no no no and
as that you have to watch it all because
by the time you get to the last episode
you don't even remember what was
happening in the first people yeah how
did you come to do that documentary
because that that sauce that what you
set out to do right and
no and we've always loved documentaries
it's actually our favorite thing to
consume but we are also practical people
and we know that if you want to direct
documentaries you will be broke and sad
because it's a very difficult business
it's the business of losing money as we
stay close to narrative filmmaking which
allows us to have children and be
somewhat happy but you know as our
company has grown we realize that like
we actually have a platform now where we
can give people money and creative
support and control and the
infrastructure to do what they want to
do so while ball country really is the
way brother's chap and Mac Way who
directed that thing and us sort of being
their uncle's or godparents surrounding
them with the protection and cash they
needed to make it the way they needed to
make it how what do they do they come to
you and say like look at all this
incredible footage we have and we have
access to hundred percent and everybody
yeah hundred percent you know 300 hours
of archival footage
yeah they got from Oregon and they'd
already contacted some of the people and
the and the and the package was really
good and they had taken it around town
and no one wanted to buy it really which
is insane and then literally it just
took like us taking our Duplass brothers
stamp and saying like okay we'll put our
name on it we'll just we'll just pay for
this so that you can do it the way you
want to do it and we'll and we'll we'll
set you up and I would like to say that
we were the creative geniuses but it
really it's right how do people avoid
the trap of when making documentaries
falling into pushing one side of the
other because making a murderer was
really interesting but it made me angry
because I'm like they're pushing Steven
Avery sighs and so much you can feel the
agenda and they're yeah I mean these
guys if you see these guys they look
like they're basically Bros in their
late 20s like they have no business
having this level of equanimity or
respect or just like appreciation for
somebody like Sheila I mean they're
really unique amazing human beings and
like Mark said we didn't have to like
baby them or anything like that I mean
it was also by the way they had
previously made this this documentary
called the battered bastards of baseball
have you guys seen no no it's it is it
is a top notch absolutely it's it's a
it's almost like a perfect oh it's it's
about a little league not a little a
triple-a is a baseball team in in Oregon
that basically the business of working
with with coming up in baseball
basically yeah they're kind of this
independent triple-a team which is odd
and they build a team full of like the
best eighteen year olds and like the
forty year olds we have one year left so
it's almost like the real-life Major
League and they do it just so that they
can sell beer and have a business but
then they start winning and the major
league teams start getting very upset
about this and start dropping their a
players down to triple-a to beat them
and they still keep winning and it is
really interesting it's almost like with
springtime for Hitler all that becoming
shitty and it becomes good so when you
would you do something like this there's
Netflix now come to you and be like okay
now fine it's the next one now fine it's
the next one yeah we have these great
relationships with with Netflix and who
we do a lot of movies with and in HBO we
do a lot of our TV work with and I think
we're they're bottom feeders essentially
you know like they they they need to go
find the next Game of Thrones and the
next huge thing and they need to put
their attention on that and they don't
have time to find these smaller things
but they sort of trust us as almost a
little like sub-label of them yeah to go
go find things that are good and
interesting and we make them cheaply and
it's a really beneficial relationship
for everybody
we basically signed our deal with them
when they did their big Adam Sandler
deal and I think they were like hey
we're still weird and cool too and you
booked this call it's just called like
brothers and there you guys are doing a
whole big book tour we won't mention all
the date but just say tomorrow you're
gonna be at the Smithsonian associates
at here's Horne Museum in DC and Friday
at the Alamo Drafthouse in Austin Texas
you can pick cool places to do this and
then the JCC is San Francisco Saturday
and then the region Theatre May 16th in
LA so those are all cool places to do a
sign they kind of unique places - yeah I
mean we don't really perceive ourselves
as authors you know we're
filmmakers who decided to write a book
and I think for us you know if there's
something special we had to offer it was
really telling people how we came from
absolutely nowhere with no connections
and were just desperate enough to keep
going to build the system on our own and
then I think that you know along the way
we sort of we developed a pretty unique
bond as as brothers and a way of I guess
communicating with each other that was a
total absence of ego a total value on
what the two of us could do together by
kind of subordinating our individual
selves right yeah which was very helpful
but also now that we're older realizing
like maybe a little unhealthy at times
why codependent yeah oh yeah total mess
if there's a great part in the book
where you you you go over a concept that
you had for a movie the [ __ ] thing
that you couldn't make and then you tell
the short story and then you put in the
emails that went back and forth are the
emails real yes all right yeah it really
is an exchange that just goes from like
oh I really appreciate that feedback to
okay you just really hurt my feelings
like that
yeah it's it's people think it's strange
and they they think we're lying but the
way that we argue I guess is just like
it seems like like a couple that has
been through like deep relationship
counseling language we've been doing
this since we were kids I think what it
really comes down to is like I think we
knew from a very early age that we
wanted to make art we came from a very
sort of like orderly Catholic school
background in New Orleans and we didn't
know anybody who was successful in the
arts and subconsciously we just knew
that like if we were gonna make this
happen we were gonna have to link arms
and put everything aside and prioritize
our relationship too because you know
when you're when you're when you're
heading out into the unknown like to do
it alone I think we both just felt like
it wasn't one gonna happen we're gonna
have to do it together
so what point do you guys realize we
don't just want to make films you want
to make films with people like take on
the producer role like we were just
talking accidentally it was totally
accidental we
like the first people in our group of
friends to make any money as filmmakers
and then all of our friends were still
making their little like ten thousand
dollar movies and we were getting a lot
of like oh god I'm supposed to film
tomorrow and I lost $4,000 of my funding
and we just have survivor's guilt so
we're like here take the money and then
we did what we normally do we help them
with their watch their rough cuts with
their scripts we help them get into
Sundance and and someone looked at us
one day I was like you guys are
producers we're like oh yeah I'm gonna
get a blazer I'm a producer and J have
to ask you how are you doing with
transparent I know you guys are shooting
the fifth and final see how it's got to
be an awkward situation how is it being
handled and how do you feel that yeah I
mean it's I think first and foremost
it's like kind of like dealing with like
the disillusion of a family you know
because it's been such an incredible
experience along the way making this
show being part of a civil rights
movement and just being really close to
everyone in the family so and that not
only includes the cast but just like the
crew and you know I was told recently
the trans parent is like the
second-largest employer of transgender
people after like the US military so
it's like really kind of like a special
thing and to have it kind of be being
torn apart a bit from the inside out has
been tough I mean honestly I just feel
so grateful to be a part of it I mean I
wasn't even an actor before this show
this is such an unusual experience for
me and it's kind of helped me discover
that acting is a huge part of what I
want to do I think right now it's just a
matter of it's on Jill Soloway the
brilliant creator of the show and and
you know what they have to deal with now
is how do I finish a show which is
already really hard to do how do I make
Amazon happy how do I you know honor the
transgender community how do I like
honor the legacy of their family because
this is ultimately a show about Jill's
family and what they were Father right
her daddy our father transitioned late
in life and and that's what the
character of Moreh was based on so it's
pretty easy pretty easy just luck
there was like a weird Jeffrey did an
interview in the The Hollywood Reporter
where he kind of said that they were
trying it seems like there was this push
because he's not trans to get him out at
one point so that might have been the
reason they used to get him out or maybe
they pushed to get him out what are they
doing with with the character are they
killing moral off of how are they
getting rid of the character or is that
mapping decide oh no I think Jill is
just diving deep right now I think it
you know Jeffrey was let go from the
show a couple of months ago only so
there was an investigation and Jill at
the time was developing like two or
three potentials as to what this series
might be whether it would be rebooted
now it's only pretty recent that we know
that this will be the last season and
that Jeffrey won't be a part of it
so I think you know Jill is just going
deep right now trying to figure out how
to do it yeah could we've interviewed
him twice and the first time was great
and the second time we got like a little
bit testy and he said he has anger
issues so maybe that went into it - I
don't know you uh you'd have a section
in the book where you're defending the
sequel to the Karate Kid
mm-hmm which i think is an important
thing I mean people are talking about
the Karate Kid now have you seen Cobra
Kai I have seen the pilot yes what did
you think of it um I was you know what
really struck me first of all it was way
better than I thought it was going to be
yeah and I was surprised at how much I
enjoyed living in the Karate Kid Vaught
they have the vibe yeah I mean it's a
totally different show a totally
different tone but like I was kind of
enjoying being around those guys for for
30 minutes it was weird the Sun saying
this is the original sensei in it he was
not in the pilot okay um I think he's
dead he's dead he's like oh let's have
some respect no no you're talking about
the Cobra Kai look I said he's not
popped up that I've seen but he's not
dead is he Martin Cove is alive as well
and let's let's have a moment for Martin
Co it's not just the sensei have some
respect okay I thought there was
something like you know every time they
do these reboots or whatever it was the
first time I remember looking at
something and being like these guys
peaked in high school like
because they were awesome yeah when we
all watch The Karate Kid right yeah but
that that was their peak and we get to
go like okay no matter what I've done
over the last 25 years they haven't done
any better The Karate Kid was pretty
good the second one don't go back and
re-watch it bro we were kids and we
watched it we loved it and then you
watch it you don't like that dance come
on the dance was pretty good with the
with the oh my god mr. Sato let's just
analyze this for a short right the whole
premise of the Karate Kid 2 is a little
toy that swings back and forth and bonks
itself
sure the whole premise is you punched
left and right enough and then you will
do good in life give it all you got both
sides equally swinging ball is an
ancient Okinawan secret karateka 2 :
bonking left and right throws the bridge
away there's no bridge to safety come on
very very good film that was so cute - I
see oh yeah the girl I don't know really
turning me around here stuck up in a
tree the guy's a coward he won't come
out and get her it's raining it's graces
himself yes he use his belt on the Bell
cause it's like cousin Sparks very
courageous one of those things mark and
I talk about this a lot there's a lot of
movies don't you dare go back and watch
them because you know that movie I don't
know how old you were when you saw that
movie or probably like it was 35 like if
you had the feelings you weren't that
developed as a person yeah felt good
that it worked you have all these
memories about it if you go back and
watch this movie it's it's kind of a
[ __ ] show so just don't go back and
watch it like it live with the movie
that you've created in your mind that's
how I felt about the Godfather no
rewatch ability I saw it once and I'm
like [ __ ] just let the memories how
would they have gotten the horse's head
to that Bell without waking up Jack
walls no you're a dumpster fire
but you're right some films just don't
have some move you can watch a 50-ton
you're like this is a Midnight Cowboy
I never loses anything for I watch that
that's a masterpiece and then you'll
watch something else two years lady like
oh god [ __ ] labor enjoy us mark and I
talk about the Titanic we cried our
balls off in the Titanic and we started
to realize like even pretty soon after
like this is not an empirically good
movie the subjective experience we had
in that movie theater is undeniably
breakups at the time and there was like
worse it was like there was like a
perfect storm I think I was nineteen
when it came out and I I fancied myself
a young man at the bow of a ship heading
into my destiny I wanted to draw naked
girls what lost you and Yuri watched it
when Yuri watch it was like what part
did you go oh this is douchey it was
just it was like a growing dumpster fire
I mean it was like you you're watching
and you're like oh my god not that oh I
think and in truth is I think I could I
could rewatch it in my mind and know
that right bad I didn't even have to
actually yeah I couldn't have really
been emotionally attached to this in any
way shape or form yes my watch for the
first time in like years clue I said to
thank god this completely holds up it's
incredible of it it's I want to get with
my kids it good loved it really well
it's incredible clear it's really fun I
think it only gets better to tell you
the trinomial a made three different
endings and put it out into theaters and
yeah ever knew which one you were gonna
get yes awesome that's a great yeah it's
great I like better that I can just
watch it and see all three endings now
yeah feeling happy frustrating like I'm
going to see it again
yeah same ending oh you wouldn't know
which version they were showing or
anything no you weren't able to control
it yeah no because if you knew you would
know what the ending was that's a good
point
so they couldn't they couldn't tell you
did you guys do the creep movies
together or is that just you doing no
that was mostly a collaboration I did
with my friend Patrick Brice and and
blum house and and you'll kind of see in
our in our book that we wrote this book
like brothers that came out yesterday
you know that book
like that whole thing you mean the one
that your faces that's been sort of like
a celebration of like us realizing that
we have climbed this mountain together
arm-in-arm codependent Lee and now we're
realizing that a little bit of creative
space and us having affairs on our own
creative marriage with nine people has
been bittersweet but also very healthy
for us you get jealous at all each other
[ __ ] horrified percent there's a
chapter in the book called I am jealous
in fact this follow-up chapter called I
am also jealousy like creep to has I
just checked it last night as 100%
rotten tomato rating yeah do you go what
the [ __ ] you know supposed to be making
movies that are that good one well and
by the way horror sequels right yeah
should never do that it's for money not
rotten tomatoes right I think the right
way to talk about it is that I'm super
happy for my brother to have these
experiences and and have fun and and get
praised for for these things but I don't
want him to be praised too much right
because I don't want him to leave me in
the dust you don't even feel like he
doesn't need you yes
it's not like I can Tina you don't want
you to have so I feel about transparent
and I was just like so happy for my
brother to explore acting and do that
and it's so great and go off and have
new relationships but don't go too far
yeah and have a great time and and be
celebrated but don't be celebrating too
much Jose is creep the response to his
success in transparent I think creep and
transparent are really kindred spirits
[Laughter]
see the relation there you say it's it
creepy you want to do a trilogy with
that right yes we're working on the
third right now I feel like if I had
figured out a concept like that that's
like you know you can do for a super low
budget no casting you can just do it
kind of yourself I feel like I'd be like
why don't we make 50 of these we think
what we just did we do we do talk about
that sometime we do I do wonder what I
will look like as a 70 year old man
doing creep 94 so we'll have to talk
about that but
yeah III feel you you guys passed up a
Marvel movie which a lot of people
wouldn't do because you said was gonna
take you three years and you would be
out of the loop where you want to be
yeah I mean we like when we came up you
know we were lucky enough to be in that
position where the big studio projects
we're looking at young indie directors
because they get them for cheap and they
were particularly looking for people
that actors wanted to work with we're
kind of known as actors directors and
and people who are really really nice
and willing to suffer because when
you're doing a massive movie like that
it's so difficult to get all the movie
stars and all the voices and get and you
just end up getting destroyed yeah your
job is to get the movie from A to Z it's
not really to make the best movie yeah
it's just to like get through get the
things done so we had a lot of stuff
across our desk on that front and we
have for the last honestly you know five
years or so and and our take on it is
we're not like hoity-toity like oh we're
too good to make comic-book movies
because we make emotional movies like
it's really not that it's just that Jay
and I make so many things and if you
were going to direct a big-budget movie
you have to give it your unilateral
focus for three years straight and you
also have to make sure it makes its
money buy you should and we're we're bad
at both of those things it might not be
as fun as the what you're doing though
no definitely not as long as you're now
and we have this tiny little corner of
the sandbox and the you know the most
money one of our movies has ever made is
ten million dollars at the worldwide box
office but we still get to do what we
want to do and we don't want to mess
that up
is there any anxiety when you first cuz
I could in the grand scheme of things of
course that's the right thing to do but
when you first make the call like to say
no I'm not it is hard to do it and we
have to have that discussion are we
really saying no and we even had like at
a certain point in our careers what you
we consider to be one of the top three
producers in the world literally say to
us this is earlier on why don't you guys
want to be millionaires like seriously
you don't want a lighting it's really
like we're actively trying to avoid
being rich he literally said it on the
phone and I was just like oh yeah you
think about it he's right do you think
you would lose something if you had that
because there are kinds of people think
of things are too good I'm gonna lose
this drive that makes me do stuff you
know you be comfortable we are our
engine has been running with that
desperation drive in full gear you would
like to reduce the level of pathetic
desperation oh yeah we would like to the
moneygrab is here and it's called like
brothers yes in bookstores now